if you ever wonder how people ended up
drowning witches or killing neighbors in
civil wars or
following chrissy teigen on instagram
you could bet hysteria
was the driving force for years greg
gutfeld has entertained and edified
audiences by hosting fox news channel
shows such as
red eye the five and the greg gutfeld
show
and by authoring bestsellers such as how
to be right
not cool and the joy of hate now the 55
year old punk rock fan
has just published the plus self-help
for people who
hate self-help a funny yet serious book
about becoming a better person
basically it's impulse control for
people
who have options that lend themselves to
doing negative things
in a wide-ranging conversation gut fell
tells reason
why he thinks americans have so many
problems controlling our worst impulses
how we will eventually emerge better off
from the covet 19 lockdowns
and why we will re-elect donald trump in
november
greg gutfeld thank you for talking to
reason my pleasure nick it always is a
pleasure
oh yeah you know it's a pleasure before
it begins and it gets less and less
pleasurable as the time
goes on uh let me read goes up the
pleasure goes down and the regret goes
up
that's uh you know that uh also known as
saturday night right
yes um your new book uh which i read
with
pleasure and joy in a steaming hot uh
afternoon actually in washington square
park in new york
in you know quarantine new york the plus
self-help for people who hate self-help
why did you feel a need to write a
self-help book right now
first off i i i love the fact that you
read this book in public
oh yeah in downtown new york and you
didn't get
jumped um you know what it was i um so i
didn't have a contract for uh i haven't
i had a contract for a book but i didn't
have to write one for another year or so
but i had all these weird proposals that
were all like
linked stuff about social media stuff
about canceled culture
mobs and all this stuff and it was all
kind of bothering me
so i started writing these proposals as
articles and then i realized i'm really
tired
of hearing me complain so that other
people must be tired of hearing me
complain
meanwhile i'm thinking about how to make
my life better
and this idea was like why can't i
create solutions for these problems and
is there a solution yeah so i mean
the the controlling metaphor though the
big idea in the book is in the title the
plus and you talk about
you know basically you can either be a
plus or a minus
uh not just to yourself but to the
people around you can you
talk a little bit about uh you know
flesh that out a little bit and
uh explain the origins of this uh
insight which i and i don't think i'm
overselling it when i say you know this
is probably since the invention of
gravity
the discovery of gravity and the
invention of fire this is probably
the third most important thing since the
and also the beatles anthology
record being released around 2000 2001
yes well and dental floss yes
up there there's nothing more
pleasurable than using dental floss but
anyway
you were you are correct so
i have to know okay
basically it's impulse control for
people
who have options that lend themselves to
doing negative things
so i need that and i think a lot of
people need that
maybe back when religion was a bigger
deal
this would come off as super obvious the
idea of thinking before you act
and wondering before you send off that
email or that text
or saying that thing to your spouse you
wonder is this a plus or a minus
like is what i'm about to do gonna make
things a little bit better a little bit
worse
most people would call that impulse
control it would be
it was a it was a a practice of
improving yourself
because you knew you were flawed and
that's what religion was for religion
basically said you were screwed up and
you need that you need the ten
commandments you need these you you need
rules but we've we've jettisoned all
that and so
as you get older and you become i'm
gonna i mean i'm not gonna as
as i became more successful in life
options present themselves in which
impulse control becomes a huge deal
and i i think by the way i think impulse
control or lack thereof is a huge deal
right now
as we're seeing across america that we
have how do you mean how do you mean um
you know impulse control are you telling
me that uh you don't think that people
who are riding not people who are
protesting
and spending time in writing down
placards and and organizing but
you know rioters and looters you don't
you think that they have an impulse
control problem
i think anybody who commits crimes
knowing
that they uh in the long run it doesn't
pay
we were taught that has some kind of
impulse control i would put myself in
that
yeah well you know what a great a great
example of lack of impulse control
is drinking knowing you're going to have
a hangover the hangover
you know that's that's the most obvious
way and i mean looting is a destruction
of your community
and it and it i think it's also a crime
of uh
opportunity they you know what happened
in chicago happened because they knew
they could get away with it but there
would be some kind of impulse control
that would say you know this is wrong
there are people that own these
businesses there are people that work
here i have friends that work at this
place they're not going to be at work on
monday
because the store won't be here this is
the second time we've looted this place
they're not coming back the insurance is
no longer going to be there it's like
it's like impulse control
i feel like we're living in a stage
where we see impulse
we say we see moral judgment or any kind
of judgment is somehow
uh bigoted or or uh or or mean
what about uh donald trump does he have
impulse control problems
i think so i think so but thankfully
it has it's almost entirely verbal yeah
like he doesn't start wars
right you know he's not like that he's
not that he's not we've had this
discussion
that uh generally uh everybody gets mad
at donald trump about his personality
um but that does his personality doesn't
lead to
death i would rather take a guy with
a thousand upsetting tweets uh
a week over a guy that creates a
thousand body bags
you know and that's and i know that it's
not that's the prison of two ideas i
know that yes
yeah which is a great concept in the
book about you you talk about the prison
of two ideas and
and you emphasize that that journalist
especially but and i think it's more
than journalists but journalists
especially love the idea that it's
it's this versus that it's always yes or
no it's always binary so
yeah and i just did it now i did it now
but because it is such a relentless
criticism for four years
and it doesn't change it's like dude
okay we get it
trump's obnoxious trump's tweets piss
you off but
if you wake up every day surprised by
trump
or by trump's words it's like being
surprised that there's
we wake up to uh sunrise right or that
you know it is something that is going
to be there
until it's not well both the sunrise and
trump and trump
trump are orange right um
can i uh you know be i i want to you
know stay on
on the self-help question a bit um for a
second but
um you know one of the things you you
said like
you know it's it's about being plus
rather than minus in like the myriad
all of the different interactions you
have every day can you you know can you
make people around yourself can you make
yourself feel better or do better
in each interaction i want to i want to
uh cut to the chase though because we're
you know we're roughly the same age and
we have a lot of similar tastes and we
you know we both
were raised uh roman catholic went to
catholic schools and things like that
i know for myself and i i don't want to
speak for you but i think i know you
well enough like
the you know a lot of the stuff you like
you're wearing a melvins t-shirt
uh you know there is so much negative
energy
that i draw on every day you know and
and this is what i liked about punk this
is what i liked about the sex pistols in
the clash and the angry samoans
and groups like the melvins and whatnot
that you know there's
energy and being negative right um how
how did you flip that switch because it
is also true that if you're pouring acid
all the time eventually you know it
starts getting on your shoes
and it starts eating at your feet and
moving up your body how did you flip
negative energy into uh into being a
plus
that is a great question because i've
been thinking about it a lot
in terms of music that you're right okay
so i
loved punk from i mean i loved
everything from the mid 70s on
and a lot of it's a lot of it was
nihilistic
which is so that is so great about it
yeah it is and i'm wondering but here's
the thing
i don't know if it influenced me because
i don't know if i
understood the lyrics at the time like
okay so i
my favorite band was the clash and they
were like they were they dressed like
you know
uh um outlaw communist cowboys
right right and uh their third their
triple
album was called sandinista right i mean
and i
and i'm like i don't know how old i was
that was 1980 so i was 16.
and i didn't even know i knew what the
san antonios were i had to do a report
on something
uh for my religion class at sarah on
central american politics and yeah so
either this
is like it's falling into your lap right
there yeah
but so now i have i bought uh a record
player and i'm listening to
a lot of this stuff and i'm like one i
don't like this
and the great thing about the melvins i
have no idea what they're singing about
and i think that even uh king buzzo has
said
that it's only it's like he chooses
words
or how they sound and the same thing
with mike patton chooses
lyrics based on how the words sound and
if it and if you are
reading into this although i do think
that the the
the last buzz of king buzzo album he's
doing with trevor dunn
actually has some lyrics that are uh
that aren't pointed
you know but the the other thing though
is i am almost
like i would say i've moved to 80 to 90
instrumental
electronica ambient music because i
don't
i find that lyrics i don't want other
people's thoughts in my head
i was never like that i love having
thoughts in my head
but i don't like other people's thoughts
in my head it's too crowded in there
i don't need to be i don't need billy
joe armstrong telling me that you're an
idiot you're an american idiot yes
right we're allowed to still use
nationalist terms like america
i love but that's a great album you know
uh american idiot or whatever it's uh
so it i mean to me one of the things
that uh you know
as i was reading your book in washington
square being egged and pelted with
garbage by all the opioid losers who are
not social distancing in washington
square park
i was thinking of this irony and this
paradox that
there is so much great negative energy
coming out of punk but then
you know but then you you need to do
something with that energy and i and
that's what i like about the book
uh one of the points that you make in
the book that i want to uh kind of talk
about
is you at at some point i'm going to
butcher the exact quote which is much
better worded than what i'm going to say
but you you basically said you know it's
really important to take
a couple of moments every day and
recognize that when you get all pissed
off and bent out of shape over politics
that it's
not that important or that's not the
limit of your life
can you talk about what you mean by that
general insight again i i
apologize for paraphrasing it so if i
forget
that the people that i'm talking to
aren't in my profession
or i'm just hanging out uh and that i
realize that what i'm talking about they
have no idea what i'm talking about
like i could be and it's like oh geez
uh i can't believe trump loved him to go
like whoa what happened and then and
like
like i have friends that work in uh in
auto in
like classic cars and they like they
they know i do a show
and i have friends that are in rock
bands they know i do a show but they
don't even watch
and it's like so it's like i don't even
bother with hey did you check out the
show
some people do but generally a lot of my
aside from my family
you know and some friends you know it's
like people are doing their own thing
they have more of an allegiance and an
emotional connection to sports
way more than anything political they
start thinking about politics in october
maybe
um i think trump has been different
because he's been so
magnetic that everybody including the
people that love him
or and hate him are drawn to him i don't
think there's ever been a personality
like this
right or they're pushed away like a
magnet like you either
get stuck to him or you you can't even
get close to him
i guess the word is polarizing which is
an overused word
but uh i think you know um
like when i'm around people nobody talks
about politics unless they want to talk
about it with you
because you are in it but generally it's
not there and then also it's like
it's it's weird okay so if you're not
living in the city you can get
engulfed in social media and think the
world's gonna end right the world's end
you're watching chicago manhattan
uh seattle portland whatever but then
you go outside
and if you're living anywhere outside of
a city there's no impact whatsoever you
can walk out
walk around the trees and i do this i i
bought a cabin in the woods
a couple years ago and it's like it's a
universe
uh wait i'm sorry did you say it's the
una bomber
that you are now going to be the
unabomber you're living in a shack
in the woods yeah here's an out of
context yeah
a part of this interview you know he had
some good points there you can put that
in there
living out in the middle of nowhere is
really good for your brain
however you know i can't like
say going outside is the best way to get
away from this stuff
the only problem is if you're living in
manhattan or if you're living in these
cities
that cloud still follows you also if
you're um
in the public eye uh you can be canceled
whether you're on twitter or not just
because you don't look at twitter
or facebook doesn't mean there's you
know 50 people
that are trying to generate this idea
that you're a scorch
and you need to be completely black ball
and
in in the book i mean uh and if if i get
your position wrong please correct me
but
um i mean you're not saying that people
shouldn't be
you know going back and forth on twitter
and you know and if you say something
you might you might get praise or you
might get criticism
but what you're talking about is a kind
of over-the-top cancel culture where
people
are not even in you know they're not
interested in talking about ideas or
even agreeing or disagreeing it's about
cutting you know cutting somebody's
knees off at every given moment
it's a power move that uh
people who perceive no power
or think that they have no power uh
engineer in this matter gives them a
sense and it's maybe fleeting
but uh if i got rid of i mean i'll get
people that are trying to come after me
and
uh and they'll be uh i got you you're
going down it's like who cares
it's like what is this gonna do for you
or your family i don't understand this
and maybe maybe there was maybe i got a
thrill out of this
i don't know i don't think i ever did i
think i've always pretty much defended
people who even i didn't like and uh
and these people never almost never
returned a favor
could you uh yeah well you you you tell
a very good story and
uh you know ed like all good self-help
books you are the hero of every story
you take exactly
uh but but you talk about how you were
wrong about the the covington catholic
uh
school kids uh nick sandman uh the you
know the big showdown between the
vietnam war
vet who was not quite a vietnam war vet
american indian protester
versus you know punky uh magga hat
wearing
uh you know upper middle class kids from
a uh catholic school
outside of uh cincinnati in covington
kentucky what did you get wrong and what
did you learn
about kind of eating your words on that
that instance
well the scenario is a familiar one for
me at saturday i'm drinking at a place
and
and i've noticed that my tweets don't
get drunky
they just get more frequent so if i if
i'm sober and i'm
eating i will tweet maybe twice a day at
the most and they'll be pretty good
but then if i'm drinking i'll have like
like 10 and they're they're not like
stupid
they're exactly the same but the fact
that you do the more frequently
increases the risk for trouble so your
sponsor
your your your sponsor has like a
twitter a
notification like oh my god greg hit
three in an hour i've gotta do it
internet
but um so i was there and so i'm sitting
there it's like one o'clock i'm working
on probably this book
and uh and i'm watching the covington
stuff and there was a thing
that i did which is like ridic which is
like
it's it's a it was a strategy so i'm
watching this i go well you know
if people are going to trust me in my
criticism i have to police my own side
too
right i i can't just go after joy behar
or bill maher i've got to go after this
punk this punk in dc
making fun you know so i said something
wow i think i wrote something like this
this kid should be taken home without
supper and spanked or something like
that
and then of course like two hours later
we find out that
you know anybody like there's a couple
of human weaknesses once the willing the
the desire to be first
you know i'm gonna get there first then
there's this mimicry
uh that you look around and see what
other people are doing and you do that
um which is the mob kind of thinking
which i actually
hate and i think i kind of played a role
in that in a tiny little way
um and then um just the idea
that you think that all your id all of
your thoughts are worth hearing
why can't i just shut up don't i know
what you're saying shut up
i am gonna shut up after this interview
but for now why why do i have to tweet
why do i have to why do i feel like
they're not even paying me
this is the stupidest thing about
twitter nick is that
i can be more likely to be fired for
doing something
free than doing what i'm paid to do
because i'm sitting on twitter and you
know i'm like i'm every time i'm
you're tweeting you're kind of jumping
off a little clip you know so stupid i
don't understand why i'm doing it
but anyway when i realized i was wrong i
didn't i i went out of my way i wrote a
piece on it i did
i think i did a monologue on the gg show
and a monologue on the five
because i felt that the restitution was
necessary and perhaps it would help
if people saw that hey i i'm going out
of my way
to say i'm an idiot that other people
will like oh okay
that's i mean it's it's a really nice
moment in the book and i remember that
kind of in real time but i think
uh it's it's a great example of trying
to you know to walk the uh
walk that you're uh that's a terrible
line i'm sorry to finish it this way
to walk the walk that you're talking in
the book
um how does how does the you you note
in the book you started writing this i
think in january there about so it was
before the
the covet 19 pandemic and lockdown
how does that fit into the scheme like
you know because
one of the things that the pandemic has
done is really i mean
everybody's kind of pissed off nobody
trusts anybody because we're being told
you know one day we're being told by
tony fauci
where don't wear a mask they don't do
anything then the next day oh no you
really got to wear a mask and i was
lying to you
and he's the least objectionable figure
in this in this whole drama
obviously you're good friends with him
if you call him tony well you know as an
italian
american on my mother's side i have you
know there's a club that we belong to so
um but but what i'm saying is um you
know this is a particularly
bad moment i mean on top of everything
else that's happening you know this has
really rubbed things raw
how does how does the pandemic um uh
you know intersect with being a plus or
a minus what what are the ways to do
that because
you you take a bunch of pot shots uh at
governor andrew cuomo
mayor bill de blasio of new york rightly
i think but
you know everybody is mad everybody's
angry at somebody
yeah you know uh the book went the book
was sent off to the printer
before the pandemic and i pleaded with
them to add that
first chapter on it to talk about it
because there were ideas in the book
that apply directly to this issue
including the prison of two ideas
where you're faced with we're not faced
with a choice of lock down
or back to work and then back to where
people will die
lockdown economy collapses that's the
prison of two ideas that we're
constantly
going over every single day and it's
like no we we we have
adjusted phases that can go back and
forth and lateral and
vertical whatever but the other thing
too that i try to say
and to your point about blaming and not
blaming is if people
uh made decisions you uh
with with the information that they had
and then the information later proves
them wrong
you can't really blame them for taking
us taking a stance
you could especially if they change it
immediately if they go like
um like so many doctors including fauci
said uh no keep you know go on that
cruise i think fountains
keep going on that on those cruises and
you don't need to wear a mask and then
of course all that changes and you
realize the reason why they were saying
don't wear a mask is they didn't want to
run
on masks which is what you were kind of
seeing anyway
so they touched so they they basically
tried to lie to help
and and and ease the burden so to speak
and then they then they backtrack and
say this so nobody trusts them
but i i i say that you have to you can't
keep pointing fingers
now the reason why you can point fingers
at de blasio
and cuomo is the fact that
that's a weird noise uh that de blasio
was wrong on almost everything he was
saying
and going after people who are trying to
do right
and also just the rest home thing is
just idiotic and
i think what bothered me most about
cuomo is cnn
kind of because they have his uh his
brother
and that they had the brothers show uh
the smothers brothers
there is a sick joke in the smothers
brothers
yes why did i think of that but i'm not
um mom always killed you
first yes i'm not gonna yeah it's like
i'm not gonna make but so you have these
that you have these guys being lauded by
the media while
six thousand sixty two hundred people
died in the rest homes in new york
who didn't have to and they're lecturing
us and going outside and
wearing masks and then they just you
know shunt all these uh all these
contagious
patients in so um
assigning blame you gotta be if somebody
has some skin in the game and took a
risk and said do this and do that
i don't get i and they end up being
wrong that's
as long as they change and they and they
adapt that's how it works with a
pandemic you don't know
and by the way we are all going to go
back to like this this death rate that
is going to be really low once we
realize
how big the cont how contagious it was i
mean it was like
i think it was like in march i think it
was the death rate
nationwide was like six percent now it's
over at one and i bet it'll it's gonna
go
at one percent by the way still high
blood connections
and it will probably go down even more
as we realized how large
this thing is but so everything keeps
shifting and we have to be
fairly compassionate to people when they
are wrong
but i really don't like people who don't
say anything
until afterwards and then the armchair
quarterback you know
and and uh and saying oh you know looks
like you really had a terrible plan it's
like
what were you doing do you think um you
know
i and i want to talk uh briefly about
how
how you think that we might end the
polarization that you know seems to be
everywhere
um but before we do that can do you
think things are worse now in the book
you
you do talk about you know kind of media
and social media new forms of media
the hyper politicization of everything
um
is it worse than say you know in the
late 70s or something when
you know you started being conscious of
of a kind of adult world of discourse
and
you know people people liking reagan to
hitler people liking
bill clinton to hitler you know people
you know everybody
everybody has you know five minutes you
know andy warhol was wrong and
in the future everybody will be liking
to hitler for 15 minutes
um is it worse is it worse um and if so
why is it worse
and the irony you know the one person
who wasn't liking to hitler
was hitler somehow he he escaped that
yeah
well he's a wily old fox right yes still
alive in argentina
yes
but is it is it do you think it's
actually worse than it used to be
um i think it's just more there's more
platforms
to make it feel overwhelming and i think
the i think
uh the profit model for news because of
social media
is now about discontent it's like they
realize they've done the research they
know that the clicks are driven by
that inside feeling of like and it's
like um
i just saw a great story
about it was a headline from an english
newspaper do you spend time in england
so you know how the press works there
which
is kind of paradigmatic of this but it
was about how uh
a guy said that when he was a fat kid in
the 70s ellen degeneres fat shamed him
i i know so what i mean now we're going
to go back we're going to go back
okay so did you i fight i'm pretty sure
i teased
somebody in third grade i'm not sure i
was pleased but i mean like that
this is where we're going and they
actually print that art they print that
article everything is publishable
everything is publishable which i thank
god for on my own
uh you know for my own outlets but yes
it's it's a bit much
tell me uh let's we'll wrap up in a
couple minutes here but um
how do you propose to reduce
polarization or
you know to escape the criminal the
mental criminal justice reform to get us
out of the prison
of two ideas greg got felt i do
i do believe that the first thing we
need to do is is conquer
uh cancel culture because i think uh i
think people that that keeps people
scared uh so we need to share the risk
everybody needs to defend other people
that they don't even like and i know
that's altruistic there's also the idea
of mutually assured destruction
which you know if somebody comes after
nick gillespie by going to reason
magazine and saying you employ
uh nick gillespie who uh cannibalizes
you know i don't know well humans and
then
because we are human thank you you have
the i know it's not often i can give you
a compliment
but uh but then you have the right to
call that person's place of work so i
feel like
i would love to see a law though i don't
like laws
like people who come after you to cancer
we need to know where they work i would
love that but i think
sharing the risk is the best is the is
the only way we're gonna get through
this
um in education which is i mean you and
i are probably the same pages we need
a complete overhaul because we are
creating zombies
and uh they're coming into our human
resources
they're leaving the campuses so
we need we need innovation i always i've
said this a couple times
what peloton did to education i mean
what peloton did
gyms blank is to education
we fill in that blank we change
everything like peloton
the gym and change the way people
exercise at least for now for
rich people who buy things first do you
think
um do you think that the the lockdown
and the quarantine which
you know it seems to be sticking around
longer than i think a lot of people
expected um do you think that might be
one of the benefits that it is
it's you know even as we move more
online
it's also kind of forcing people to
rethink things
we are shaking the box on all things
including just like
walking around the city you can walk
around the city with a drink in your
hand now in manhattan
and i don't think that's going away the
open uh the open dining up until i guess
until winter
now but that might end up being
permanent i think you know
incorporating like online studies with
in classroom stuff is going to be
permanent but maybe we can even
build on that i think there's going to
be a lot of things like a lot of the
working at home stuff and the zoom stuff
is going to be helpful i do all my
meetings at home um
and uh and security is changing so many
weird things are changing uh oh i mean
like
we're not gonna be handling money much
we're not gonna be
dealing with people if at all i mean
remember
all those restaurants that they're
they're opening in airports three years
ago where you just go to the thing you
type in your
eggs benedict bottle of wine that was
right and then it would just
somebody would come out and drop it
there that's the way it's going to be
yeah and that's that's a beautiful
vision of the future
hey here's a here's a weird thing just
did it have you re-thought about eating
out
as like a weird kind of artificial
pleasure
because now you're at home and you're
going like how much money
did i spend thinking that i had to go
out and eat
and now we're i'm talking to somebody
with no kids uh
and a young wife and i just we just go
out and i'm like what
it's like now i'm living like a normal
person i go like and i walk by
restaurants and i go now i'll just go
home and
cook something now that they're open i
wonder if when you break a habit
when you break a habit can you like even
with watching sports
how hard is it to get back into it like
you know when you love a team like the
49ers
and then they have two bad seasons and
then did you break that habit
so you don't come back to them or or
whatever do you see my point i don't
know i know i
i mean i think you're right and i guess
the question now is we need to get busy
on figuring out what comes next because
we're we're kind of at the end of the
road yeah we are the clash
circa cut the crap uh clash
we know that the future is unwritten and
we need to come up with new bands
the audio dynamite is reforming so
there's good for that
um what you know in in the book uh in
your previous books which i've i've read
and enjoyed um you talk a lot in in
previous interviews
uh and on your shows you talk a lot
about the uh influence of andrew
breitbart
um on you and and kind of as a culture
figure
where even people who are on the other
side of the political fence actually
have adopted a lot of the insights
and a lot of the temperament and kind of
sensibility of andrew
um but uh of the light andrew breitbart
in this book you talk
a bit about scott adams uh he comes up
pretty regularly
and you know he's the the creator of
dilbert
um he is a somebody who has been
identified as a trump supporter even
though he
is pretty much at pains to say he
expected trump to win for
he predicted that trump would win for x
y and z reasons put it out there was
right
um what is the value of scott adams what
what do you think uh you know why is he
so appealing to you and why do you think
uh it's not just you that
he actually is one way of thinking about
a different way of talking about stuff
that might actually bring us together
rather than
having us kind of at each other's
throats all the time yeah i would go
as far as saying that he is quietly
influencing a country
probably more than we think it has a lot
to do with the powers of persuasion so
he was
interested in donald trump because he
saw a master persuader person who could
use words
uh to great effect and so it wasn't that
he was a trump supporter he just
he was just like wow this guy's got game
and he also says by the way he says the
same thing about aoc which i agree as
well she has
she has definite skills and he talks
about a talent stack
of being good at a number of things and
i just discovered
him by accident because i had written uh
read a book by jesus
called influence um by childini
uh i can't think of his name first name
but let's say his last name's childini
and i i read that book and i thought wow
this describes
donald trump to a t and i don't think
trump was president at the time so i
wrote these articles three articles
on how influence predicted donald trump
and
uh and then some guy on twitter and this
is where twitter helps some guy goes
dude you should just go read scott adams
blog he just
basically covered this six months ago so
i went and i looked and i go holy crap
everything that scott adams has been
talking about for the last i don't know
two or three years
i thought i discovered and then i
started he does and
he does this podcast every morning in
which he gets up and he just talks about
stuff from a persuasive point of view
and it's it's it's entertaining
it's it's uh it's it's i think it's just
he's an original thinker and i find that
he rises above the left versus right
by talking about what's persuasive and
and also
the idea of how to come up with new
things
as opposed to keep doing the same old
thing and i think you know it's always
about questioning
shaking the box let's see what happens
right and i think it's a you know it's
he it's kind of weird how a lot of his
ideas
anticipate what happens next whether
it's
coupling you know or uh or or shutting
down travel for china
i mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
eerie things that he predicts
it is um he's also an example as you
were saying about doing new things uh he
you know he conducts these podcasts or
these interviews or
you know monologues really uh via
periscope
and you know this is a guy who has a
massive empire in kind of legacy media
through the dilbert cartoons but then
rushed into new ways of of being in
contact with an audience which is pretty
interesting
do you feel that way i mean you know
it's funny now uh you you
are hugely successful uh if i'm right uh
uh if i if i believe i'm right when uh
the greg gutfeld show
on fox over the weekend on fox news over
the weekend does better than most other
shows even on
on network shows much less other cable
shows in terms of
massive audience or do you you're you're
a uh
you know a kind of emissary uh from like
what's now considered legacy media do
you see yourself
shifting into new modes of interacting
with your uh
with your audiences that are different
than what you've been doing
i don't know i don't know that's a tough
question for the last question nick
last well you know well let's uh get
three last questions and i have to go i
have to go to i gotta go to the i gotta
go to the five
you gotta go to the five okay i gotta go
okay final final question for greg
gutfeld
author most recently of the plus
self-help for people who ate self-help
and i'm going to put you on on the spot
not who do you want to win
the presidency but who do you think is
going to win
in november is it going to be trump or
is it going to be joe biden
and does it matter i think it's going to
be trump
i i do i just don't i i i think that
we've got a lot of people who are pissed
off
and silent i might be one of them i
don't think you're that silent
yeah and now that you're all plus you're
plus you're happy you can't be pissed
off either
okay well we will leave it there we've
been talking with uh greg gutfeld he's
the author most recently as i said of
the plus self-help
for people who hate self-help uh greg
thanks so much for talking to reason
awesome thanks buddy